about those comments made by
um Ben Wallace I'm not Amazon to put it
into context he said you know at one
point he drove 11 hours to Ukraine to
talk to them about military assistance
he was effectively presented with a list
is this just a bit of frustration here
from the um defense minister you know
the UK can only go so far so fast yes
and I you know I think politicians get
tired after 11 hour trip you arrive
there presented with a bit of a list of
the ukrainians are always demanding
because they're fighting a war for their
own Survival and on behalf of a lot of
other NATO countries no more uh sort of
abstract sense so I think you've got to
allow for the fact that people get
irritated with each other and that
happens at NATO meetings all the time
you know you've got third in this case
you've got 32 allies plus guests plus
four uh of a big guess Australia New
Zealand Japan South Korea you've got the
EU there a lot of people behind the
scenes get quite irritated and that's
not it's not surprising that these
things happen they they rise a bit but
remember zielinski gosh he's been
through I think three or four meetings a
week in last few months I'm always
turning up on video always in his combat
outfit always having to inspect people
to say the right things you know the
mask slips occasionally and the man is
getting tired I mean lots of information
from Kiev say look he's getting tired
he's he's not Beyond getting irritable
he's getting quite difficult to work
with in some ways because this is what
happens to war leaders after 15 or 16
months yeah because he's quite vocal
going into this Summit about Ukraine's
NATO membership saying you know we seem
to have a lot of words but not a lot of
action in us being you know ascended
into the alliance at this point on day
two of the summit what are NATO offering
Ukraine at this point because there
hasn't been an official invitation for
membership no they're saying that there
will be an invitation you know when the
when the conditions are right I mean
NATO has never given the time frame to
anybody who's joined the alliance I mean
Alliance was 12 originally 1949 and then
it was 15 and then 16. it stayed at 16
for many years and then suddenly it went
from sort of 16 to 22 and then 25 28th
so 30 31 now 32 and as it goes up it's
never given the timeline to any state
and the other states still as we're in
the waiting room who would like to get
in and there's some years away as well
Georgia is one of them so that's not
surprising but in the case this is so
extraordinary that here's here is a
country fighting for its life biggest
single land area in Europe apart from
Russia itself it's what it would be if
it comes into the western family of
Nations fully in the next few years
it'll be one of the big five you know
the big four in Europe are as a Germany
France Britain Italy those are the big
four well Ukraine will be a fifth would
be one of the big five in say 10 or 15
years time so there's big things on the
horizon and nobody will give Ukraine a
precise timeline because they're the
other fighting of war and as kajikala
said the Estonian prime minister was
very clear on this she said you know if
if Ukraine came into the alliance this
month then next month effectively we'd
all be fighting Russia and that's not
what anybody was including Ukraine so
what we're looking for is when is the
right moment it's probably not the end
of the war because that will be
Generations away a couple of generations
away that might be 20 or 30 years but
we're looking for let's say a ceasefire
and there's a ceasefire Point NATO could
then play this really important role in
stabilizing a ceasefire but that
ceasefire probably probably
won't liberate all of Ukrainian
territory so some big compromises got to
be made here yeah it's difficult isn't
it to work out a timetable a NATO you
know the leaders probably haven't got
their heads around that themselves
um but we are expecting a press
conference
um from the Secretary General of NATO
against altenberg and that should be
coming up later this hour I understand
and and we are expecting new security
assurances for Ukraine
what might that mean in Practical terms
and will that be good enough for
president zielinski who's got hot under
the collar going into this yeah I mean
he's been a lot of a lot of bilaterals
so um I mean what president Lynch is
getting out of this is the the the
respect of being given a one-to-one with
President Biden one-to-one with soon act
one-to-one with the Secretary General
everybody wants to be photographed with
zelinski he's the man of the 21st
century
um so he'll get lots of bilateral
assurances and the G7 later on today who
happened to be there this isn't an
official G7 meeting but the meetings are
all there and they are going to announce
something which will have a series of
words in it and security guarantees but
none of these guarantees will be an
automatic guarantee to go to war for
Ukraine as Article 5 of the NATO treaty
is interpreted to be in reality you know
there's a lot more wiggle room in
Article Five than people think but it's
actually been interpreted over the years
since 1949 as an automatic declaration
that we will all go to war for any one
of our members who is attacked doesn't
actually say that but that's why it's
been interpreted so we're not going to
resolve from that because if we then if
we then sort of went back to what what
it actually says which it actually says
well we'll all agree commonly to discuss
what to do on the assumption that an
attack on one's an attack on all if we
went back to that that would that would
degrade Article 5 for the future so
Article Five has got to be interpreted
as an automatic War
um article which it isn't but that's the
way we interpret it and we're not going
to give that to Ukraine while it is
still actively fighting and so you know
we're back at this conundrum now lots of
people can give bilateral guarantees
Britain has already said that because
you know we gave we and the Americans
gave Ukraine a bilateral uh sorry a
trilateral guarantee in 1994 when it
gave up the nuclear weapons it is
inherited from the old Soviet Union we
guaranteed Ukrainian security and then
forgot all about it in 2014 when they
were attacked and what we said is well
because the Russians have actually
driven a coaching horses through it the
whole thing doesn't apply anymore so the
ukrainians keep reminding us and they
said you've guaranteed our security in
1994 look where we are now we've been
attacked twice since then you've done
nothing that's not true but you know we
haven't done enough to prevent it